and concerns from our community tonight
about the impact violence within the
school district is impacting the mental
health of children fact is just one
issue that families will touch on
tonight during a community discussion
victoria saha joins us from the newsroom
with more victoria
yeah denise this discussion had a very
powerful name it was called ptsd within
ccsd diving into the after effects the
pandemic and the recent uptick of school
violence and how that's impacting our
youth
no trauma is too big or too small trauma
a battle our students are faced with
every day some are fighting a silent
fight and others are lashing out
everyone's angry you're locked in your
homes all like thoughts piling up and
stuff so i feel like everyone's taking
out on each other the escalation in
recent brutal attacks within ccsd has
made headlines we didn't know about it
until we saw it on the news and the lack
of transparency from the district is
stirring fear among students and staff
we're really facing a real situation
right now a major situation i've never
had to put my hands on the student in
regards to stopping a fight i've had to
do it twice school board trustee katie
williams was amongst the panelists
hearing herself what changes can be made
because on friday there's a special
session to discuss this very topic the
board wants to address you know student
safety issues and let people know let
parents know that we do care tuesday
evening's discussion had a common theme
in regards to bullying and violence we
must address the lack of teachers the
lack of support staff the lack of hall
monitors and the lack of resources for
our kids who are going through the
largest mental health crisis in the
history of our nation they all agreed it
wasn't just a ccsd issue but everyone
needs to play a role in making sure our
students are ok
so that special meeting is set to start
on friday morning another suggestion
that was made is that change starts at
home our children are watching our every
move instead of judging them on what
they do wrong teach them from right from
wrong victoria zaha live local now
victoria thank you